we have to wrap up I know you have to go  but I do have one final question the CGI  in the film how much was uh practical  how much was in in camera that had the  uh it's a restoration Center this is a  Spitfire behind me no no I don't I don't  mean the planes I mean the the sex scene  how much how much was uh CGI I mean it  looked good you know I like I could  almost imagine you being a real human  being and not a robot you know it was  that Vivid  so really  bad bad joke all right I I think that's  an understatement isn't it  I've I've never had sex so I wouldn't  know that's incredible that is  absolutely incredible anyways  congratulations  it's really what you've accomplished I  have great admiration for